قال حكيم شبه جزيره القرم سيرجيه اكسيون
اوف ان حريقا اندلع داخل قاعده جويه في
منطقه كيروسوفسكي في شبه الجزيره واضفنا
السلطات المحليه بدات باجلاء نحو الفين من
سكان اربع بلدات قريبه من القاعده
العسكريه موضحا ان الطريقه السريعه الذي
يربط مدينتي سباستوبل
والسمن حيث يوجد جسر القرم اغلق بسبب
الحريق
وقالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان اثنين
او اثنتين مسيره من طراز شاهد هجمت
الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
كما قالت ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت صواريخ
من طرازك ليبر من البحر الاسود باتجاه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بينها اوديسا اضافت ان
الهجمات بالصواريخ والطائرات استهدفت
منشات عسكريه والبنيه التحتيه في اوديس
ومناطق اخرى
معنا منسك مراسل الجزيره مازن ابراهيم
مازن اذا تصعيد في منطقه البحر الاسود
والروس يستهدفون مدنا ساحليه منها اوديسا
هل يمكن ان تخبرنا عن ابرز هذه الهجمات
نعم في الواقع كما كان متوقعا بعد انسحاب
روسيا من اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب احتدت
المواجهه في تلك المنطقه تحديدا ما بين
اوديسا وشبه جزيره القرم وياتي هذا الامر
انسجاما مع خطين الخط الاول الذي يرتبط
بالتصعيد العسكري على كامل الجبهات والخط
الثاني المرتبط بموضوع تصدير الحبوب عمليا
ما نشهده منذ نحو 48 ساعه هنالك منازله
جويه صاروخيه كبيره بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
ضمن هذا الفضاء الممتد ما بين شبه جزيره
القرم وصولا الى اوديسا ومحيطها عمليا على
المستوى الاوكراني قياده الاركان اعلنت
بان القوات الروسيه اطلقت 31 صاروخا من
طرازات مختلفه وانواع مختلفه بما فيها
كاليبر استهدفت مجموعه كبيره من المناطق
الاوكرانيه في طليعتها اوديسا وكان
الاستهداف وفق قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
هو يرتبط بمواقع عسكريه من جهه وايضا اخرى
ترتبط البنيه التحتيه سواء في ميناء
اوديسا او مناطق متفرقه من اوديسا هذا
الامر ترافق ايضا مع اطلاق مسيرات روسيه
من طراز شاهد الايرانيه على مناطق متعدده
سواء في اوديسا او في عمق البلاد وذلك في
محاوله لاستهداف القواعد العسكريه وخطوط
الامداد الاوكرانيه من قبل القوات الروسيه
وهذا الامر الحق اضرار متعدده في اماكن
متفرقه من البلاد ولكن بطبيعه الحال هنالك
تحفظ حتى الان من الجهه الاوكرانيه
للاعلان عن تفاصيل الاستهدافات وان كانت
تشير الى ان جزءا كبيرا من الصواريخ قد تم
اعتراضها بالاضافه الى المسيرات التي وصلت
الى عمق الاراضي الاوكرانيه واستهدفت
مجموعه كبيره من المواقع المدنيه
والعسكريه
عمليا هذا من ناحيه اوديسا وشبه جزيره
القرم والاحتدام الصاروخي وعبر المسيرات
والذي نلاحظه خلال اليومين الماضيين يضاف
الى كل ذلك ان هنالك تطورات على مستوى خط
الممتد من خركاف وصولا الى خرسون هنالك
تطورات وان كانت لا ترقى الى مستوى احداث
تغير كبير على مستوى التموضع كلي فريق
ولكن القوات الروسيه التي كانت تضغط في
كوبيانك بالامس وكانت تتحدث عن تقدم وهذا
ما كانت قد اكدته خلال الايام الماضيه
النائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هي اشارت
بالامس وايضا من خلال البيانات الصادره
صباح اليوم بان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت
من صد مجموعه كبيره من هذه الهجمات
وبالتالي ما بين محور الايمان وصولا الى
كوبيانس هنالك محاوله تقدم روسي واستمات
اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن تلك المواقع عمليا
كنت بالامس في الايمان وقد شاهدت الارتال
المدرعات والامدادات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
التي التي كانت تدخل الى تلك المنطقه في
محاوله لمنع القوات الروسيه من التقدم الى
الايمان ومحاوله اطباق الخناق على حيث
اتواجد حاليا بالاضافه الى كروماتروس
وغيرها من في مقاطعه ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن تقدم على مستوى
الجنوب وشمال مدينه باخموند في هذه
المقاطعه مقاطعه بالاضافه الى عمليات
عسكريه تنفذها في مقاطعه وهي تقول بان
القوات الروسيه في تلك المقاطعه هي في
موقف دفاعي
والهجوم تنفذه القوات الاوكرانيه في
محاوله منها للدخول في اعماق هذه المنطقه
واختراق خط الحدود ولكن بطبيعه الحال
هنالك مجموعه من الملاحظات المرتبطه
بالواقع الميداني في طليعتها ان حقول
الالغام الكبيره التي زرعتها القوات
الروسيه على طول هذه الجبهه تعيق تقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه بشكل كبير لا بل انها
اعاقت كل المخطط المرتبط بالهجوم المضاد
الذي بدا قبل سته اسابيع ومن الواضح انه
دخل في دائره من المروحه من الهجمات
والهجمات المضاده التي تنافذها القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ويمكن القول
بشكل واضح وفق كل التقييمات سواء كان
التقييمات عسكريه اوكرانيا او حتى من خلال
مراقبين اوروبيين وغربيين وامريكيين
الجميع يتقاطع عند نقطه اساسيه بان هذا
الهجوم المضاد قد تراجعت حدته بشكل كبير
نتيجه عوامل ترتبط بالواقع الميداني وبعدم
قدره كل الاسلحه التي تم تجويد اوكرانيا
بها على احداث خرق كبير على مستوى الجبهه
نتيجه اعتبارات متعدده في طلعتها السياده
الجويه الروسيه على مختلف الاجواء في طول
خط المواجهه بالاضافه الى حقول الالغام
والخنادق التي والتحصينات التي اقامتها
القوات الروسيه طيله الاشهر الماضيه بما
يعيق اي عمليه تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه
شكرا لك مازن ابراهيم مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من